on a rarement vu un discours de l'état
de l'Union être aussi chahuté est aussi
bon dérangeant c'était le cas hier soir
Joe Biden donc qui était là Frédéric qui
s'est adressé aux représentants au
sénateur à parler d'unité etc mais on
comprend alors que ça a pas été apprécié
par tout le monde dans cette chambre
en effet Marc-André en fait jobiden
était un peu comme un funambule en
équilibriste entre nommer tous les
accomplissements législatifs de son
parti depuis les deux dernières années
ils sont quand même assez conséquents
mais aussi il fallait lancer des flèches
la décocher des flèches à l'endroit du
parti républicain parce que selon
Monsieur Biden le parti républicain s'en
va vers une direction qui n'est pas très
profitable pour les américains selon lui
et donc lorsqu'il a dit que bon certains
républicains voulaient attaquer les
programmes sociaux comme médical médical
mais là on a entendu vraiment ceux qui
font partie de la frange un peu plus à
droite du parti républicain comme
Marjorie Marjorie tiller green critiqué
vertement crier même le traitant de
menteurs le président américain donc on
a manqué un peu au décor en fait c'était
un petit peu voulu en quelque sorte pour
pour de la part de Monsieur Biden parce
que bon il faut montrer qu'il est
l'homme de la situation et que le parti
républicain n'est pas celui qui est à
suivre mais il y avait quand même un
message d'appel à l'unité voici un
extrait de son discours hier soir au
Capitole
normalement on attend ça on entend ça
des présidents démocrates plus
protectionnistes alors c'était le cas
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça c'est pour
soutenir l'économie faut que tout soit
fabriqué et acheté aux États-Unis
mais voilà l'idée de Monsieur Biden
c'est d'utiliser cette fameuse close
américaine qui est évidemment très
vendeuse pour un politicien donc oui ce
qu'il voudrait c'est qu'à partir de
maintenant l'ensemble des matériaux de
construction qu'on va utiliser pour les
grands projets d'infrastructure ou pour
les édifices fédéraux soit vraiment fait
manufacturer ici aux États-Unis ce qui
veut dire forcément qui durera
probablement des recours devant les
tribunaux de la part du Canada parce que
bon quand on parle de bois d'oeuvre et
d'aluminium il y a quand même certains
accords commerciaux qui faut respecter
mais en même temps écoutez cette bonne
guerre le côté très American American
American c'est ce qui est beaucoup
ressorti hier du discours de Joe Biden
voici un autre court extrait
ce soir j'annonce de nouvelles normes
qui exigent que tous les matériaux de
construction
utilisant des projets de
d'infrastructure fédérales
j'exige et cette loi il exigera qu'il
soit fabriqué aux États-Unis oui
fabriqué aux États-Unis d'Amérique et ça
c'est du sérieux je rigole pas
que ce soit du bois d'oeuvre du vert du
Gyproc des câbles de fibre optique et
ce sont des produits américains qui se
retrouveront dans nos routes dans nos
ponts dans nos autoroutes
alors voilà donc il n'a pas le choix
monsieur Biden parce qu'on lui prête des
attentions de lancer une campagne de
réélection pour 2024 dans les prochaines
semaines donc vendre les produits
américains c'est évidemment assez
VENDEUR sauf que la plupart des
Américains souhaiteraient un peu plus de
relais faut rappeler que Monsieur Biden
à 80 ans mais quand même ça reste
l'homme fort du Parti démocratique pour
l'instant t'es plus dynamique mais
longtemps qu'on avait pas vu dans un
discours comme celui-là le plus plus
animée alors merci beaucoup Frédéric à
la prochaine
bonne journée
à insisté pour favoriser c'était une
petite phrase qui touche les Canadiens
vous allez savoir pourquoi pour
favoriser les produits fabriqués aux
États-Unis dans les projets
d'infrastructure fédéraux donc les
matériaux de construction tout de suite
on pense au bois d'oeuvre mais
certainement l'acier à la vitre
également Michel Vincent était
économiste en chef du Conseil de
l'industrie forestière du Québec et là
pour nous en parler bonjour monsieur
Vincent
bonjour quand vous avez entendu monsieur
Biden mentionner ça encore une fois hier
dans le discours avez-vous l'impression
vous êtes vous dit ça y est on
recommence la même bataille
non pas vraiment en fait le discours
protectionniste qu'on a entendu hier
vous savez dans des périodes ou de où on
observe des tensions commerciales
politiques diplomatiques à l'échelle
internationale on s'en aussi attend ce
que les policiers du coup plus
protectionniste à l'égard de la
population américaine alors c'est pas
une grosse surprise et puis
nous on dans le dossier du bois d'oeuvre
évidemment ce n'est pas le discours
c'est plus la réalité terrain qui qui
fait fois tout et puis celle là elle est
elle est très lourde et puis elle est
très elle appelle un discours non
protectionniste alors pour nous le
dossier suit son cours comme d'habitude
ça ça veut dire quoi pour l'industrie du
bois par exemple parce que là si ça se
matérialisait demain ça veut dire non
seulement faut embaucher les avocats en
fonction de l'Accord de libre-échange
avec le les Etats-Unis le Mexique le
Canada va contester ça si vous ne pouvez
pas vendre de bois d'oeuvre non
en fait on est en litige présentement
2017 et je vous rappelle que c'est le
cinquième litige donc on est dans la
septième année du cinquième litige
depuis 40 ans donc pour nous c'est un
peu c'est devenu un élément structurel
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
le
discours américain ou les Américains en
fait présentement ils sont en déficit de
logement de 6 millions il manque 6
millions de maisons pour répondre aux
besoins les États-Unis et le et puis ça
donne que ils sont potes ou suffisants
65 70 % de leur besoin en bois sont
comblés par les industriels américains
mais le reste le bois doit venir
d'ailleurs si bien pas du Canada il va
devenir il va venir d'ailleurs mais il
peut pas venir des États-Unis ils ne
sont pas tous suffisants alors cette ça
c'est la réalité et qui présentement on
est dans une période de haute inflation
on essaie de travailler pour réduire
cette inflation là et le tout coup qu'on
apporte qu'on est qu'on est inclut qu'on
ajoute au bois d'oeuvre faire augmenter
le prix des maisons garde des ménages
des familles à l'extérieur qui ne
peuvent pas
acheter leur propriété qui ne peuvent
pas venir propriétaire ça ralentit
l'économie encore plus et
ça c'est la réalité qui fait que
éventuellement
le bon sens va finir va finir par
l'emporter comme il l'a toujours fait
dans les quatre premiers litiges faut
être patient comme des Canadiens des
Québécois pour se dire ça fait 40 ans
qu'à chaque fois en fait on va se le
dire qu'on gagne c'est litiges là mais
vous ça veut dire que des usines qui
fonctionnent un petit peu plus au
ralenti parce que on peut pas trop se
stocker vous pouvez pas livrer de bois à
la même vitesse en temps normal puis les
Américains payent la taxe parce qu'ils
en ont besoin on est obligé de réduire
la production non
les exportations évidemment sont pas au
niveau qu'elle sait qu'elles étaient ou
qu'elle serait s'il y avait en mode de
taille sur le bois d'oeuvre mais avant
tout il y a des périodes où les prix
sont très bas ou les producteurs sont
frappés directement les tilleurs par
exemple mais pendant de longues périodes
dans la dans un cycle économique ce sont
plutôt les consommateurs américains qui
payent la taxe parce que la demande est
tellement supérieure à l'offre que les
prix que les taxes sont refilés aux
consommateurs américains puis jusqu'à un
certain point consommateur canadien
aussi alors ce sont les consonnateurs
qui payent le qui font le qui font qui
payent sont les grands perdants de ce
litige là et puis quand on est
consommateurs payent plus cher c'est de
l'inflation de plus et s'ils peuvent pas
construire des maisons ben c'est de la
récession qui est aussi on s'en liste de
plus en plus dans les session le bois
d'oeuvre c'est un produit de première
nécessité pour l'activité économique et
il y a une grosse partie des Américains
qui le comprennent déjà alors au-delà du
discours protectionniste hier ça c'est
la réalité qui est là et
la base démocrate une grosse partie de
la base démographique on les retrouve
chez les milléniaux les mileniaux sont
les gens le groupe de population le plus
actif au niveau
achat de résidence de première résidence
souvent et c'est pas en imposant ou en
maintenant des taxes qui qui va les
aider à devenir propriétaire ou à faire
se faire construire leur première maison
bon mais il faudra suivre ça quand même
même si à chaque fois on a plutôt raison
devant les tribunaux parce qu'après tout
il y en a beaucoup de gens au Québec au
Canada qui c'est leur gagne merci
beaucoup Monsieur Vincent d'avoir été
disponible à la prochaine au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI